it's been really nice Keanu Reeves
reacts to fans dubbing him a respectful
King for the way he takes photos with
women but but it no it's nice
he spoke with the actor shortly after
the internet went wild over how Keanu
takes photos with women without wrapping
his arms or hands around their waist
instead he hovers behind their backs or
in his pockets but turns out the poses
aren't just reserved for women he seems
to do the same with guys et spoke with
Keanu on the red carpet at the premiere
of his latest film Toy Story 4 where he
proved yet again he's one of the most
humble guys in Hollywood it's been
really nice it was really special for me
like just how about John wick film was
received and then also you know just
recently would always be my maybe and
then been connected with CD Projekt RED
I've just been had the chance to be
working with really cool people and a
part some really cool cool projects and
so I'm gonna be here in the Toy Story 4
there's a lot of fun
Gaby Gaby has four key you know the
perfect toy to help no dude no dude no
no way
[Music]